momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a la
compañera daniela blandón empezamos en
eeuu porque hay polémica por la
exigencia de vacunación en las empresas
cuentas así desde andrés pues mire la
decisión del presidente estadounidense
joe biden de obligar a las empresas de
más de 100 empleados a exigir a sus
trabajadores que se vacunen contra el
cubil 19 o que se hagan pruebas
semanales ha dividido el sector privado
sobre el efecto que puede tener en la
recuperación económica hay compañías
grandes como google united airlines
mcdonald's y walt disney por ejemplo que
no sólo han estado de acuerdo sino que
ya habían implementado estas medidas por
su cuenta pero muchas medianas y
pequeñas empresas que tienen menos
recursos que las multinacionales
rechazaron la orden presidencial la
asociación de negocios de texas que
tiene más de 1500 miembros aseguró que
la decisión del presidente se tomó sin
consultar a la comunidad empresarial lo
que casi con certeza
conduciría a una mayor politización del
cob y 19 y agrega que marca un
precedente aterrador daniela en países
bajos habrá igualdad de condiciones para
taxistas y conductores dv pues a por lo
menos así lo determinó un tribunal de
amsterdam que dictaminó el lunes que sus
cerca de 4000 conductores de uber son
empleados y no contratistas como ya ha
sucedido en varios países de europa y
por lo tanto están sujetos a los mismos
derechos laborales de los taxistas
holandeses
significa que van a recibir un pago
honesto por el trabajo que han realizado
durante los últimos cinco años con
efecto retroactivo eso podría significar
una indemnización de cientos de euros al
mes y quiere decir que ahora están
protegidos por el convenio colectivo
acumulan una pensión están asegurados se
les paga durante las vacaciones o por
enfermedad andrés y über por su parte
dijo que condena el fallo y además que
lo va a apelar bueno daniela y en 2022
se reactivará la demanda de petróleo que
había antes de la pandemia como eso esto
lo dice la organización de países
exportadores de petróleo que asegura que
el consumo mundial superará los 100
millones de barriles por día el próximo
año este es el nivel que había antes de
la pandemia y llegó a bajar más del 10
por ciento en el peor momento de la
crisis o sea en unos 10 millones de
barriles el mercado petrolero en el
continente se está moviendo mucho por
estos días entre otras cosas por los
efectos del huracán aida que ha
provocado escasez de suministro y eso ha
tenido consecuencias también en los
precios el barril de referencia w y para
el golfo de méxico ya supera los 70 por
primera vez en 6 semanas y los precios
del gas natural están en su nivel más
alto en más de 7 años
y hay buenas noticias para los españoles
pues españa busca reducir los precios de
la electricidad pues este martes se va a
someter a aprobación del consejo de
ministros un plan para que las facturas
de la luz no sigan presionando las
finanzas de los hogares esto después de
que en las últimas semanas los precios
en el mercado spot o sea andrés el valor
del día a día del que depende al menos
un tercio de los consumidores hayan
estado en máximos históricos el jefe del
gobierno español pedro sánchez no dio
mayores detalles pero sí tildó de
inaceptable que las prestadoras del
servicio estén beneficiándose de los
altos precios reveló que la medida
incluye por ejemplo un techo a los
precios del gas y reducción de impuestos
medios locales hablan de que incluso se
va a prorrogar una orden que impide que
se corte el servicio por falta de pago
indicadores del día
o street del cerro mixto el lunes en un
pequeño respiro después de haber cerrado
la semana pasada con perdidas el mismo
rebote se vio en las bolsas europeas que
también estuvieron influenciadas por las
buenas perspectivas de las que hablamos
de la opep y en cuanto a américa latina'
los mercados de argentina reaccionaron
de manera positiva al revés electoral
sufrido por el oficialismo en las
primarias legislativas de este domingo
la bolsa de buenos aires por ejemplo se
disparó en más del 5% y nuestra cifra
del día 1000 millones de dólares en
compromisos de asistencia humanitaria
para afganistán que logró la conferencia
de donantes organizada este lunes por
naciones unidas aunque admitió que no
podrá a brindarse o brindarse si no se
trabaja junto a los talibanes pero una
cosa es lo que prometen y otra lo que
efectivamente desembolsan que por lo
general es mucho menos en esta reunión
antes recordemos participaron en más de
100 ministros exteriores de un centenar
de países
al hígado hablando como siempre con la
información económica muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y ustedes también muchas
gracias por sintonizarnos quédense con
nosotros
[Música]